uh they have resolved their differences
breaking news in the last three minutes
uh the judge in the trial which was two
hours and a day late getting underway um
said just moments ago they came back in
to go and said the parties have resolved
their case uh in other words uh they
have settled now there was always
speculation that this might happen but
it was expected it would happen before
now not in the the last few moments
before this trial was was set to get
underway we don't know at the moment
what the details of this resolution are
but it was always the case so said media
commentators who have been watching this
extraordinary and very very important uh
trial that was due to get underway they
always believed that it was never in Fox
news's interests and in its parent
company's interests in Rupert Murdoch's
interest to see this one go to trial to
allow the Bonnet to be lifted on the
inner workings of Fox News it was always
to be from Fox his point of view a much
better outcome if they could somehow
come to a resolution with Dominion
voting systems that is the company that
operates these voting machines that are
used up and down the country and were
used during 2020 the 2020 election to
come to a resolution with that company
now clearly it involves money it will I
imagine involve money that is paid from
Fox to Dominion that they are happy with
so that this never actually comes to
trial but I tell you another has been
um huge anticipation over the course of
today and of course the trial was
supposed to get underway yesterday on
Sunday night dramatically the uh the
judge said that it would be delayed by a
delay by a day that prompted uh
speculation that the lawyers on both
sides were talking that fox was trying
to come to some sort of a resolution but
there was nothing confirmed today they
swore in the jury six men six women from
Delaware asked to be in court for the
next five weeks or so from now 930 to 4
30 to listen to this extraordinary case
play out this afternoon at 1 30 the
trial was supposed to begin but then we
sat there in court for two and a half
hours in silence no one knew what was
going on and then as I say a few moments
ago that word from the judge where he
said uh simply that it had been resolved
his words uh precisely were um
uh I've lost it now but the two parties
have have resolved uh their differences
resolved their case
and indeed we're hearing the judges not
provided details as you said and the
word had been that it was Fox News that
had been pushing to settle that Dominion
were pushing back hard
um believing obviously that their
reputational damage to them was
extremely costly Mark so pushing hard
not just on price but also what sort of
apology they might expect so all these
details still to emerge
thank you
yes I I we just don't know any of the
details at the moment um is this simply
a a deal that has been done that is
going to involve money I'm going from
one side to the other will there be some
sort of a public apology from Fox will
they admit wrongdoing
um they've always claimed of course that
they did nothing wrong that they were
simply reporting a news story as it was
back in 2020 this extraordinary
conspiracy theory that without evidence
that somehow these Dominion voting
machines up and down the country had
software inside them which allowed them
to take votes that had gone to Trump and
and apply them to Biden thus giving Joe
Biden uh the election that was the
central allegation that you'll remember
we all remember was peddled at the time
by the likes of Rudy Giuliani former
mayor of New York such a trump loyalist
became Donald Trump's lawyer and was out
there day after day after day in those
days after the 2020 election in November
2020 initially alleging just fraud that
something ordered happened because they
they couldn't understand how vote at the
beginning of the Eden of the evening
Trump was doing well then suddenly Biden
was doing well The Logical reason for
that as we now know is that to do with
postal votes people who vote for for Joe
Biden tend to vote by post and those put
those votes are counted uh later uh so
that was the real reason but at the time
it was alleged by Trump's people that
there was a mass fraud taking place and
then they involved Dominion voting
systems saying that they were somehow uh
involved in this Mass steal of votes and
the central allegation to this case is
that fox took that allegation and ran
with it as as fact and why did they do
that well it's alleged they did it
because they were very worried they were
losing viewers it was all about keeping
their viewership and to keep their
viewership it's alleged that they needed
to Peddle
um information which turned out to be
false and over the course Anna of the of
what's known as the discovery period
prior to of the trial taking place we've
seen numerous exchanges between high
profile anchors on Fox News celebrities
here in America people like Tucker
Carlson Laura Ingram and others text
messages and exchanges which suggest
that behind the scenes they didn't
believe the Dominion conspiracy they
said that it was nonsense and yet on air
they they appeared to be peddling it as
if it was some sort of a fact now Fox
News has always claimed in this
discovery process that Dominion is
taking Fox quotes out of context and it
doesn't show the whole picture of course
we'll never now get to hear that
official argument uh in the courtroom
because it will not go to trial
that will actually disappoint some
people certainly so the breaking news
they're brought to us from Mark Stone in
Wilmington Delaware